enjoy your first day
[Music]
as i release through the doors
i couldn't believe it
it wasn't just some crazy dream
[Music]
i might actually get away with this
my stomach's churning over tying itself
up in knots
[Music]
i got on the bus
i'm praying that i'm never going to see
this place ever again
[Music]
the best starts moving
it felt amazing it felt great
i'm feeling more and more free and less
and less like a prisoner
but the closer we get to the border i'm
getting so nervous
the last bit of the journey is the most
dangerous
the best drives up to
the checkpoint there's guardiola
everywhere
[Music]
not every car gets stopped
so when we got pulled over
my heart literally dropped into
my stomach
i stand out in venezuela with blue eyes
i can't have the guardian seeing my
my eyes
if it's a guardian that's worked in the
prisons he's going to recognize me
myself
so i pretend to be asleep
i'm praying that they don't ask to see
my passport
if they scan it gonna pop up that i'm a
prisoner
when the guard asks the guy next to me
i'm thinking this is it
i'm
and then he asks me for my passport
before i've had time to to think the bus
driver says there's no point in talking
to the gringa she can't speak a word of
spanish
okay
laguardia doesn't question it
i literally cannot believe what has just
happened i feel
like i've got guardian angels around me
[Music]
i've just escaped prison i deserved my
sentence
but i'm getting closer
to nikita
[Music]
it was the best feeling in the world
[Music]
i can't believe that's my daughter in
front of my eyes she's five years older
and
she looks so different
i said you know what my name is and she
said no and i said my name's natalie and
she said are you my mommy
i said yes i am
your mummy and i always will be
[Music]
you